hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our
1858 match between thomas wilson barnes
and paul charles morphy
and while deciding for the title on this
video uh i just went with
uh what you're seeing because i mean
it's true what happens in this game is
is just uh i mean i'm pretty sure after
this saga is over uh we're just gonna
say oh man
oh that barns and uh this game is no
different so now without further ado
let's just check it out as it's uh well
it is just a very crazy game
so barnes again with the white pieces
opens with e4 and if you're wondering
why
most of the times barnes is white and
morphe is black it's because not all of
the games were
were recorded so we are only using what
we have
uh morphe again goes for e5 we have
knight f3 d6
again now morphy goes for his philidor's
defense d4 and now morphe goes for the
philidor's counter gambit with
f5 and already we feel that it's going
to be a great game so barnes
captures an e5 of course if morphy
recaptures then he just gives up a pawn
and also he loses castling privileges
so with f captures on e4 now forces
barnes to move
the knight with knight to g5 uh and now
d5 by morphe and with this move morphe
really
improved his uh well central control
however he allows
e6 from barnes and already barnes is
preparing to reach the position from the
thumbnail
uh morphe continues with bishop to c5 he
doesn't care about knight to f7
and barnes goes for it and we have
already reached the position from the
thumbnail
there's also a very interesting idea
that instead of knight f7 you can
actually play knight captures on e4
point being that if the pawn is captured
then you have queen h5 check and you
pick up the bishop
uh but black can then go for bishop b
for check
and then we have a very very complicated
game but white should always
be on top after let's say c3 you block
the bishop
now the capture is on e4 and now queen
to h5 check there's no bishop on c5 to
capture now but still g6 bish
queen e5 and you know attack the rook
and the bishop and
white white will always be better here
so uh this is
this is one possibility however barnes
wait for not went for knight to f7
and it's still uh still a very very
complicated game morphe goes for queen
to f6
it's now morphy who's threatening
checkmate on f2
so barnes defends with bishop to e3 he
blocks the morphy's dark square bishop
and now while you could just simplify
with captures captures and captures
allow barnes to grab his
uh rook on h8 morphe instead decides to
complicate things and he goes for d4 he
goes for a nice pawn push in the center
and now he allows barnes this very
unpleasant bishop to g5 where okay now
you could capture an e6 then the knight
is captured
however morphy prefers to keep the queen
close to the bishop so he goes queen to
f5 now says okay if you capture the rook
i'm just gonna win the bishop
and then at some point i'm gonna win win
that night as after a bishop captures on
e6 comes that night it really doesn't
have
an escape square from h8 so here
uh how you should continue this game is
by playing bishop the c4
uh say sata say to murphy
uh i'm not touching that rook because i
can always capture that rook and
you will have problems developing if you
capture i'm only then going to capture
and after queen captures on e6 then i'm
gonna capture on h8 and the queen will
be unable to capture the rook
so bishop to c4 is the way to go and it
really
puts a lot of problems in front of black
however
barnes went for the immediate knight
capture sun h8 and he gave up the bishop
on g5 and it is as of move 10 that this
position has never been reached again
so morphy grabs the bishop we have queen
captures on g5
and only now bishop to c4 so this is how
barney decided to do it he said
i'm going to defend the e6 pawn now and
next move i'm going to bring the knight
back and i'm actually going to save this
knight
morphy says okay you do that knight to
c6
again morph is all about development
which we can we can definitely see here
with knight back to f7 by barnes uh he
even gives up the g2 pawn he doesn't
even care about castling against morphy
i mean that
that barnes he he's like
the the greatest guy possible i'm
definitely getting a t-shirt
with a mr barnes you know face after
you know not after this game but at some
point
so queen captures on g2 goes for uh
uh wilson's rook and now rook to f1
defending
and now knight to f6 morphe just
continues developing and he says
that's uh that's a fine knight you have
there but what what is it doing actually
uh and here while you don't really have
all that many good moves now with
white uh like queen to d2 may be
followed by queen g5
you try and uh maybe trade off the
queens and then you try and survive this
attack because barnes is up material
he's up the exchange
however it's not all that pleasant uh
with with these spawns and so many of
morphy's pieces out there
the queen is also very close to the king
so instead after knight to f6
barnes tries f3 and it's uh it's really
uh an ambitious move like
what what is it doing okay it's
restricting the movement of the knight
on f6
and also maybe threatens to open up the
f file for for barnes
rook but i mean you're you're not the
one who's attacking here and it seems
like
every game against morphy barnes gets
this beautiful initiative
and then he just uh he just you know
loses the thread of the game and then it
doesn't matter what the position is
barnes just continues attacking he's
he's he he's awesome uh so here morphe
goes for
knight to b4 uh he puts pressure on the
c2 pawn threatens knight captures on c
to check and if this happens it's game
over black has no squares the queen will
have to capture and uh
the white queen will be lost so here of
course uh barnes went for knight to
a3 to defend the c2 pawn but now uh
morphe gets
a beautiful move in and it's really uh
it's positions like these that morphe
really shows where where his strengths
lie
uh so feel free to pause the video here
and find the absolute best idea for
morphe
while i give you a couple of seconds
uh so for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
the nastiest of threats uh
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show yes d3 is fine this will win the
game but bishop captures is just the
quickest idea
because here you don't have a good reply
like
do you capture the bishop do you not
capture the bishop not capturing the
bishop
it just loses the bishop captures knight
and then you can
capture this guy then king captures it's
just you know you will give up too much
material
so barnes decided to capture the bishop
but now comes the move you had to see
in in order to simply find bishop
captures an e6 and that's
knight to d3 check so similar tonight to
c2
knight to d3 now shows that the king has
no squares and now
uh the problem is if you capture with
the pawn you no longer have this c3
option
uh so bishop before check just wins the
game the king still has no squares
you'd have to block with the queen and
now queen captures is just
game over so instead barnes decided to
play queen captures on d3 he is up
material so
he says okay i'm just going to grab a
little bit more material while giving up
my queen
but morphy just plays e captures on d3
and now barnes
just castles queen side uh the black
king is still in the center of the board
so
of course barnes still wants to continue
attacking but
there's a problem here queen captures on
c2 would be checkmate if there is no
knight here
so morphy just removes the defender of
the checkmate
plays bishop captures on a3 and now
there's the threat of checkmate on c2
so barnes is unable to to start creating
some sort of an attack he has to bring
the bishop back to guard upon here
but now morphy just continues the attack
d2 with
check point is if the rook is captured
you can capture this rook you can also
play bishop capture sun b2 check to
deflect the king and capture this rook
so everything is pretty much winning
here barnes goes king to b1
but now uh bishop to c5 uh just
getting that bishop out of harm's way uh
we have knight to
e5 by barnes uh and now king to f8
preparing to bring
the final attacking piece into the game
uh and now knight to d3 by barnes going
after the bishop on c5 but
uh you know here at this point morphy is
basically just playing with his food
so he gives up the bishop he plays rook
to rook to e8 and
there's just not much barnes can do here
burns captured on c5
but for the last time in this video
pause the video and
find the absolute brilliancy well i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting
well the brilliancy and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
queen captures on f1
and that's it there is no uh way out of
this if you capture the queen it's just
check and you bring a queen or a rook
into their game to deliver checkmate
or you play something like knights the
e6 check which is what barnes played
it's hard to say why barnes is
continuing this game probably
you know as the games are being recorded
to make it appear
to have lasted longer or maybe he just
enjoys chess too much or maybe
mark maybe barnes still believes that
he's the one who's attacking it's
it's really impossible to say but morphy
just captured
the knight here of course he doesn't
want to go under the mask of the bishop
and it was in this position on move 24
that
thomas wilson barnes resigned to the
game and uh another another
really incredible game between the two
of them great
great victory for morphy but it could
have easily been a great victory for
barnes
had it been for a few few you know more
precise moves
so really really a wild one i do hope
you're enjoying the
the you know this brawl between morphe
and barnes because the games are just uh
so super crazy uh and yeah uh
here of course you resign because the
threats are the same queen capture
series coming if you capture then rookie
one
and there's there's just no defending
this i mean there
there's no material left here for white
to play with
so yeah uh that's uh the game i do hope
you enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
david marcus matthew stroud uh jason
barr denise jalet and ben o'neal
and ryan doyle for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
and to join us on the stream today and
on delecias arenas the links are in the
description below
uh so have an excellent rest of your day
guys and i will see you soon